quelques heures sans gravité une grenade
lacrymogène préventive ce matin
impossible pour les manifestants
d'approcher la place de la révolution
alors que le président de la république
était encore dans les airs entre paris
et besançon
les slogans des militants cgt fo fsu et
sud n'auront été audible que pour les
riverains d'aller plus près d'aller plus
près après c'est pas si si c'est plus
plus intéressant en tout cas de se faire
entendre et de manifester notre
désapprobation s'attendait pas à ce
qu'ils nous laissent l'aborder et puis
lui serrer la main
et lui remettre nos quelles
revendications mais pour vous c'était
important d'être ici quand même bien sûr
oui il faut quand même qu'on vienne dire
qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec ce qui se
fait après une itinérance mémorielle
mouvementée et à la veille des
manifestations des gilet jaune
le président de la république n'aura
donc pas tenté de s'approcher des
bisontins tôt ce matin toute la partie
ouest de la boucle était inaccessible
pour certains juste un itinéraire à
revoir pour beaucoup pas vraiment de
solution apparemment à pied en vélo ya
pas moyen de sortir la boucle et voilà
je tends de rue après rue et non ça
marche pas
l'acidité et fermeté du côté des crs
incompréhension et résignation chez des
passants qui n'atteindront pas leur lieu
de travail
ils n'ont pas prévenu qu'ils allaient
bloquer au niveau de la grande rue au
niveau de la rue pasteur et au niveau de
la rue claude soulier cette rue devait
être accessible
donc c'est complètement inadmissible
pas un seul client dans ce café huit
salariés 80 repas prévu à midi
l'établissement devait être en dehors du
périmètre encore hier pour nous la place
n'étaient pas verrouillées et même les
agents de sécurité du centre commercial
qui sont passés hier nous ont dit que
pour ouvrir et pas de souci pour déplier
terrasse y aurait pas de problème ce
matin qu'en début d'après-midi de la
préfecture a confirmé que le périmètre
de sécurité avait bien été élargi une
décision prise cette nuit après
l'arrestation de sept personnes au moins
l'une d'entre elle avait caché des yeux
près de la place de la révolution
destinée au cortège présidentiel